[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO.
"WATTERS' WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
IN HONOR OF THE ACADEMY AWARD
OUR PRODUCERS THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE FUN TO HOST OUR OWN AWARDS
SHOW.
LET'S BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
CATEGORY.
BEST ACTOR IN A POLITICAL DRAMA.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
CORY BOOKER AT THE KAVANAUGH
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
>> I'M GOING TO RELEASE THE
EMAIL ON RACIAL PROFILING.
I UNDERSTAND THE PENALTY COMES
WITH POTENTIAL OUT OFFING FROM
THE SENATE.
I INVITED AND ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE CLOSEST
I'LL EVER HAVE IN MY LIFE TO AN
I AM PART KULS MOMENT.
JESSE: JESS HE SMOLLETT ON GMA.
HE SAID THIS IS MAGA COUNTRY.
I WANT THAT VIDEO FOUND SO
BADLY.
AND I WANT A LITTLE GAY BOY WHO
MIGHT WATCH THIS TO SEE THAT
[BLEEP] FOUGHT BACK AND I'M
PISSED OFF.
IT'S THE TRUTH.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN SENDING
BABIES AND OTHER YOUNG CHILDREN
HOME.
DO WE HAVE THE GRAPHIC OF THIS?
NO.
JESSE: THE WINNER IS, JUSSIE
SMOLLETT ON GMA.
THAT WAS A RUNAWAY WINNER.
BEST CATEGORY.
BEST FIGHT SCENE.
DONALD TRUMP VERSUS JIM ACOSTA.
>> THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> PARDON ME, MA'AM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: CNN SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES HAVING YOU
WORKING FOR THEM.
AROUND RUDE, TERRIBLE PERSON.
JESSE: SENATOR MARCH COVE RUBIO
VERSUS RADIO TV HOST ALEX JONES.
>> DON'T' TOUCH ME.
I AM ASKING YOU NOT TO TOUCH ME.
I DON'T WANT TO BE TOUCHED.
>> YOU WILL BEAT ME UP?
JESSE: SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
VERSUS ALL THE DEMOCRATS AT THE
KAVANAUGH HEARING.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE DONE TO THIS
GUY.
THIS IS THE MOST OF UNETHICAL
SHAM SINCE I HAVE BEEN IN
POLITICS.
AND IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO KNOW
THE TRUTH, YOU SURE AS HELL
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO THIS GUY.
THIS WILL DESTROY THE ABILITY OF
GOOD PEOPLE TO COME FORWARD
BECAUSE OF THIS CRAP.
JESSE: AND THE WINNER IS --
TRUMP VERSUS JIM ACOSTA.
AN HONORABLE MENTION FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE INTERN WHO HAD TO
GET HER HANDS VERY DIRTY.
NEXT CALCULATE GORY.
MOST OF POLITICALLY CORRECT.
THE UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND FOR
CREATING A SUPPORT GROUP FOR
WHITE STUDENTS WHO FEEL QUOTE
CONFUSED BEFORE, DURING OR AFTER
INTERACTIONS WITH MINORITIES.
ALSO NOMINATED, NORTHEASTERN
PROFESSOR, SUSAN A WALTERS, A
GENDER STUDIES PROFESSOR WHO
WROTE THAT MEN SHOULD QUOTE STEP
AWAY TO MAKE ROOM FOR WOMEN
BECAUSE THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
HATE YOU.
OUR FINAL NOMINEE.
MINNESOTA UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR
WHO SAYS THE VIRGIN MARY DID NOT
GIVE CONSENT TO BECOME PREGNANT
WITH JESUS CHRIST.
AND THE WINNER IS -- MINNESOTA
PROFESSOR SPRINKLE.
THAT WAS AN EASY ONE.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS AN
IMMACULATE CONCEPTION.
YOU NEED CONSENT FOR THAT.
NEW CATEGORY.
BEST POLITICAL COMEDY.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY GO BACK
HOME TO MOMMY.
THEY GET PUNISHED WHEN THEY GET
HOME.
A SHOW HEADED BY SLEEPY EYED
CHUCK TODD.
HE'S A SLEEPING SON OF A BITCH.
RICHARD BLUMENTHAL.
I WATCHED HIM SAY WE NEED THE
TRUTH.
IF WE DON'T HAVE -- AND HERE'S
THE GUY WHO WAS SAYING PEOPLE
DIED ALL AROUND HIM AND HE WAS
NEVER THERE.
JESSE: CNN'S JIM ACOSTA AT THE
BORDER.
>> HERE ARE SOME OF THE STEEL
SLATS THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT IT'S PRETTY
TRANQUIL DOWN HERE.
JESSE: KANYE WEST SHOCKS THE
PRESS IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> LET ME GIVE THIS GUY A HUG.
I'M MARRIED TO A FAMILY WITH NOT
A LOT OF MALE ENERGY GOING ON.
WHEN I PUT THIS HAT ON, I FEEL
LIKE SUPERMAN.
THIS OUR PRESIDENT.
HE HAS TO BE THE HIGHEST, THE
FLYEST PLANES.
YOU ARE TASTING A FINE WINE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I HATE TO SAY
THIS, JIM, YOU WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING?
JESSE: THE WINNER IS -- DONALD
TRUMP.
HE WINS ITER YEAR.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
JIM WAS A CLOSE SECOND.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
THE DUMBEST COMMIT CAL COMMEND
TEAR -- THE DUMBEST POLITICAL
COMMENTARY.
OUR NOMINEES ARE BETO O'ROURKE.
>> WOULD YOU TAKE THE WALL DOWN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULD TAKE IT WALL DOWN.
JIS
.IS
.JESSE: ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO CALL
MY MOM A LIAR.
WHAT DO THE FACTS SAY?
>> YOU HAVE NATIVE AMERICAN AN
SAYS HAVE I IN YOUR PEDIGREE.
>> ANY LEN YAMS AND GENZ AND ALL
THOSE PEOPLE WHO COME AFTER US.
THE WORLD IS GOING TEENLD IN 12
YEARS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND YOUR BIGGEST
ISSUE -- YOUR BIGGEST ISSUE IS
HOW ARE WE GOING TO PAY FOR
IT ^ ^?
THIS OUR WORLD WAR II.
JESSE: THE WORLD IS GOING TO END
IN HOW MANY YEARS?
AND THE WINNER IS -- POCAHONTAS.
ELIZABETH WARREN WHO REVEALED